dealing with the fastest pace of
inflation in more than 40 years
americans are borrowing money
a lot of money according to the latest
numbers from the federal reserve
americans in february increased their
borrowing by a record 42 billion dollars
we've also seen major increases in debt
noted by the big banks in their latest
earnings reports i want to talk to you
about what this increase in americans
debt means
why it's happening now
and what it could mean in the future as
lending gets more expensive
let's get into it during the pandemic
americans paid down debt and increased
savings at a historic pace but that
trend is reversing the fed's latest
report showed that in february consumers
took on almost five times as much credit
as they had the month before and more
than double what economists had
predicted jpmorgan chase wells fargo and
other banks have also reported
significant jumps in consumer borrowing
and credit card spending rose by at
least 20 percent in the first quarter at
each of the big four banks
this suggests americans have spent a
chunk of the money they put away
following the coronavirus lockdowns of
2020 and maybe borrowing to keep up
americans saved a record 34 of their
disposable income in april 2020 and they
put away 2.7 trillion dollars in excess
savings between then and the start of
2022 according to a report from ratings
agency movies but in february the
personal savings rate dropped to 6.3
which is lower than the 10-year average
before the pandemic
unlike at this time last year in 2022
there hasn't been a big government
stimulus to infuse cash into consumers
pockets
the rise in borrowing seems to coincide
with the rise in inflation to the
highest level in 40 years people often
talk about inflation being a drag on
spending because higher prices push
consumers to slow down and rethink their
budgets but inflation also drives up
spending as consumers front load their
purchases expecting that prices will
keep going up and it's not just the fun
stuff that's gotten more expensive
earnings reports showed some credit card
spending is going towards vacations and
nice dinners but a lot can be attributed
to higher prices for big ticket items
like cars and everyday expenses like
rent and gas
rent prices rose 30 from a year ago in
february and used cars and trucks were
41 more expensive than they were last
year even though worker pay has risen at
a historically high rate of 5.6 percent
that's well below the rate of inflation
so the average worker is actually seeing
inflation-adjusted wages of negative 2.7
this is all happening as the federal
reserve starts to raise u.s interest
rates which will make credit more
expensive the expectation for rate hikes
has already pushed treasury rates higher
and in turn mortgage rates and corporate
borrowing rates have increased
significantly other forms of credit like
credit cards and personal loans are tied
to the prime rate which moves along with
the federal funds rate the fed funds
rate has only been raised once this year
and still sits at less than half of one
percent but that's likely to change
quickly the fed is expected to raise the
funds rate multiple times before the end
of summer
that'll make it cost significantly more
to take on a loan the fed raises rates
to get individuals and businesses to
pull back on borrowing in order to slow
down spending the goal being that it
rains in rising prices but it can also
put households and businesses into
untenable positions causing waves of job
losses and defaults
now all this borrowing could just be a
sign of economic growth as consumers
want to take advantage of opportunities
that pandemic lockdowns and covent
worries have blocked off but it could be
a sign that without the government
pumping more money into their bank
accounts consumers are in trouble
in times like these i'd urge you to
think like brooklyn
fabulous who says i like that pizza
recipe not a slice of the pie
i'll see you next time